guys how you doing right on
yeah yeah i first first and foremost i
want to thank you for having me back
it's
always gracious to be here but i got a
beef with you man what what did i do
well i've had a long day first of all
coming here my jet blue flight was
canceled
and then you know i've been promoting uh
yeah no kidding i've been
i've been promoting the uh the gillette
fusion razor all day and then i had a
late afternoon pilates class always
hoping good for you to come here and get
the famous the famous conan o'brien
cookie yes now if you don't know for
those who don't know
the backstage cookies are so phenomenal
i've been here a couple of times and
every time i
look forward to having the cookies more
and more and today
i skipped a bunch of meals sweat like a
you know like a fat kid in church for
the pilates class
and i came here really looking forward
to the cookie and i mean i really
appreciate you having me back but
you know now alan alda's talking quizzy
quarter moto psychological physics
my blood sugar sugar's diving out i'm
shaking are you aware what kind of uh
cutbacks are happening in the network
right now our prime time is in the
toilet you're not getting a cookie
until this network comes up with a hit
we don't have cookie money anymore since
fringe went off the air oh it's good to
see you though man
good to see you we'll get you get the
man a cookie for god's sake
you know what i you come out here and uh
and the first thing
these arms it's madness nine of my arms
tied together don't make that arm
i just look at that arm it's the t-shirt
my leg doesn't look like that arm
uh it's it's insane and then
i i i hear that you were bullied as a
kid and i don't believe it
i just don't it's unbelievable yeah it's
actually like one of them comic book
stories i was a string bean kid
well just find string bean because when
i was when i was 12 i was five foot two
when i was uh 13 i was
six feet the height i am now i haven't
grown anything after that and i was uh
like a hundred pounds at five two and i
was like 110 pounds and six feet so i
mean it's just
real i had that too yeah i mean you
you're looking good though now you're
looking dad you just broke my arm
but just that's not even bone that's
just vanilla pudding in there
with some raisins in there but uh no but
uh you know and then you know teenage
kid getting to junior high for the first
time to add insult to injury i found uh
rap music as the music of choosing and
in west newbury
where the grass is green west newbury
massachusetts yeah yeah okay
god's country where everybody pretty
much listens to a hairband rock and
wears tight jeans i was wearing uh
mc hammer pants and mustard mustard
round polka dot outfits and the
airbrushed overalls with my name on it
and the hats to the side
what kind what was your hairstyle it was
i had a high top fade actually oh no no
you had the
it was completely bald i i would wear
lines in it sometimes it was
legitimately a foot high and i
died at the top so you were it was like
uh yeah it was awful yes thank you
i was that brave yes so kids gave you a
hard time
oh well needless to say i mean as a
young young kid in junior high we had to
walk
to the high school to catch our bus to
go home so i had to pass all the high
school kids every day and i got
literally i got put through the ringer
every day and you did the m.c hammer
genie danced
there yeah yeah yeah
can't touch this uh so uh now i
understand you you grew up wrestling you
even had
a you and your brothers had a ring a
wrestling ring in your house yeah my dad
is a huge wrestling fan the only time we
could really
legally get away with beating each other
up when my dad would allow it is when
wrestling was on
so when wrestling was on he'd always be
watching wrestling and you know my mom
would actually be trying to keep the
house together and i got four brothers
so we'd all siphon downstairs we had a
ring in the basement we'd make a
all of our belts out of paper we had
like 100 belts and some
sometimes the matches would get a little
a little out of hand there was one uh
one time in particular my mother's a
saint mom if you're watching i love you
and i'm sorry
trust me i cannot she's watching this
show i'm sorry too there's been about
seven things on the show already
that probably drove your mom to the
animal planet network
but uh lo and behold one of the matches
were like
the ultimate penultimate champion of the
universe and uh it actually got into a
heated battle and we're in the basement
so that's where all the tools are one of
my brothers grabs a sludge hammer
the other one grabs a chainsaw we bolt
upstairs i'm the last man in the line i
rip through the kitchen grab a kitchen
knife and we're going around
the house just like this one with a
chainsaw one with a sludge right it's
every three stooges episode
just an arm and my mom just clotheslines
all three of us
your mom took you out good for her yeah
now uh one of your signature moves
that's famous is the whole
can't see me you can't see me yeah just
like that but with one hand it's just
you can't see me yeah i
i love that see they know it uh have you
worked on other moves have there been
moves that you've tried
that maybe haven't worked you try stuff
all the time uh
you know i got that five knuckle shuffle
thing that deal where i just right
right after you can't see me i dropped
the fist on them
right but uh probably uh and then you
brush them off
hey man stop it and then drop the fist
it's like saying all right
it's time for me to win now right right
okay and then uh
this is all i do if i was a wrestler i
wouldn't do weights or anything i'd just
be thinking up really stupid
maneuvers yeah time to blow the
butterflies away
you know he's got a future i would do
that
he has absolutely got a future
coded o'brien the blower of butterflies
yeah
i didn't say the blower of butterfly
just that's what i interpreted
will not air because god is my witness
the show will not air
uh okay so that's good so and and uh
and and i want to make sure i get to
this you're doing a contest with
gillette and this is important to
mention
yeah absolutely uh gillette is in search
for the next phenom and this is this
commemorate the launch of their phenom
razor it's awesome i use it all the time
on every inch of my body i'm smooth
very very smooth every inch of your body
every inch you feel my arms
okay do it yeah that's right oh my god
you shave your arms that's right shave
everything
yeah the razor's that good i shave
everything with that razor
how much money gillette's giving you a
lot of scratch no no actually the deal
let me get in on this too the deal was
for no money
just for razors oh because i spent so
much money on all the
truck screw that races then uh i was
gonna get in here and help out with
gillette
i use the gillette that's the one when
you push the button i like that one it
massages the face as you shave
massages the other areas as well hey
come on like you've never tried with a
razor before
like i'm the only guy who's different
maybe i am
i think we should go to commercials
[Music]
[Applause]
the audience is like no we don't know
what you're talking about
now but real quick uh gillette's in
search for the next phenom it's
basically uh
fans can upload their videos on youtube
and to make a bad show even worse
gillette is actually asking for uh males
to showcase their best
ball skills
it's good i'm not going to touch that
with a ten foot player no no no i'll
clarify i'll clarify it's actually
anything you can do a great example is
like tiger woods bouncing a golf ball in
the head of a driver
then hitting it it's any ball like
wiffle ball tennis ball football
basketball baseball
upload your videos you can check out
gillettechampions.com the entries can be
entered as late as may 20th and the
chief prize is 30 thousand dollars and
you are dubbed
phenom of the universe which is at least
a year's worth of bragging rights right
yeah
and your and your prize for being here a
plate of cookies we actually stole these
from the today show yeah
john cena ladies and gentlemen enjoy
them
those are good thank you very much great
job take a break we'll be right back
everest is here stick around